can the so-called status quo of
jerusalem's old city be preserved a
long-standing agreement bans jews from
praying at the al-aqsa mosque compound
but ultra nationalist groups want that
to change and they're getting more
political support why is the issue so
contentious this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell tens of thousands of
ultra-nationalist israelis have marched
through occupied east jerusalem in
what's being seen as the latest
provocation against palestinians
every year far-right jewish groups mark
the illegal occupation of east jerusalem
by holding what they call a flag day
march
some took part in an incursion in the
al-aqsa mosque compound and raised the
israeli flag
and some jewish worshippers also prayed
violating a long-standing agreement
preventing non-muslims from holding
religious rituals there
the palestinian prime minister denounced
what he called aggression
such incursions have become increasingly
common imran khan reports from occupied
east jerusalem
flags wave in what israel says is a
celebration and palestinians call a
provocation
[Applause]
the israeli flag march part of what's
known by israelis is jerusalem day is a
holiday when israeli forces captured
east jerusalem in 1967 during the six
day war
for israel it's victory for the
palestinians its occupation
[Applause]
in recent years though ultra nationalist
israeli groups have used the flag march
to push their own agenda
a minority openly racist far-right group
like the harvard used the march to call
for the expulsion of all palestinians
from what was once historical palestine
and for the dismantling of the third
holiest site in islam the dome of the
rock in the al-aqsa moss compound
this year public security minister omar
barlev has allowed the march to travel
through damascus gate the heart of
occupied east jerusalem hamas which
rules the gaza strip is monitoring the
situation
as hamas we are not hesitate to
use any means
in order to stop and to
deter the extremists from doing this big
mistakes against our people
and our palestinians in the laksa mosque
or in jerusalem
we think that israel is doing now a
big catastrophe in this region
last year the march combined with the
forced expulsions of palestinians in the
shaykh gerard neighborhood sparked at
the 11 day war on gaza when hamas
threatened israel with rockets
mitchell barak an independent israeli
political consultant says allowing the
march to enter palestinian areas is once
again
dangerous
for israelis to fly the flag anywhere in
israel in jerusalem or east jerusalem it
makes a statement israeli sovereignty is
demonstrated there by the israeli army
the israeli police that is there and is
deciding who can march where can they
march what flag can be flown by which
people and that's going to be a boiling
point
in areas outside of the old city
palestinians clashed with israeli police
[Applause]
clashes also took place across the
occupied west bank where the israeli
army used live fire and tear gas against
unarmed palestinians
well it seems that the marchers have
actually dictated to the israeli police
uh how they're going to come in to
damask escape they've opened up another
route this was never supposed to happen
there are only a few israeli police here
despite a huge operation security
operation across the city and the
israeli police are simply overwhelmed
the marchers openly chanting hate
slogans and proclaiming that this is a
jewish only land this young generation
they're out in force believe that
completely and these people are the ones
that are backing the israeli government
and keeping it in power and as long as
that's the case they have very loud
voice at the heart of the israeli
government imran khan al jazeera
occupied east jerusalem
the al-aqsa compound is one of the most
volatile flash points in occupied east
jerusalem for muslims it contains two of
islam's holy sites the al-aqsa mosque
and the dome of the rock
jews call it temple mount revering it as
their first temple they pray at the
western wall
in 1967 jordan and israel agreed that
the wakif for islamic trust controls the
compound while israel controls external
security
only muslims are allowed to pray in the
mosque while jews can pray outside the
compound at the western wall
the wakif allows non-muslims to visit
the compound five days a week under its
supervision tourists are allowed in
but palestinians are concerned the
site's muslim identity is under threat
by ultra right-wing religious groups
increasingly entering and attempting to
pray there illegally
let's bring in our guests in ramallah in
the occupied west bank mustafa bharuti
is a palestinian physician activist and
politician he is secretary general of
the palestinian national initiative and
a former information minister in the
palestinian government in tel aviv in
israel akiva alder is an author and
contributing writer at haaretz newspaper
and in cambridge in the united states
ramikori is a syndicated columnist and
professor of journalism at the american
university of beirut a very warm welcome
to you all uh gentlemen thank you for
joining us here on inside story i'd like
to start with you uh
mr bhararti if i may
is the status quo being eroded at
alaksan and what does that mean for
palestinians
it was eroded and viciously i mean first
of all
according to the existing agreements the
israeli army has no right to enter the
mosque or control who enters it or who
leaves it
actually they've took they have taken
away that responsibility from the walks
and they are bringing in their troops
inside the mosque
attacking palestinians as they did
frequently in ramadan
but more than that they allowed what is
not allowable
which is
certain
israeli jewish people who entered the
mosque
did prayers in them in the mosque which
is a serious violation
they also
rose israeli flags which is also not
allowed
and they did that for several minutes
under the supervision and observation of
the israeli army which who allowed them
to do so
that's besides of course the attacks on
palestinians peaceful worshipers
this has become a common practice uh at
one point
in ramadan
we had more than
200 people injured
severely one of them actually died
because of the attacks of the israeli
army on worshippers so this is a very
serious erosion of existing agreements
and it is an eru an attack on the status
quo but most important it is an attack
on the rights of the palestinian people
and on freedom of religion uh mr akiva
alder i'd like to cross over to you as
far as
lapid is concerned uh he says the status
quo remains israel is committed to the
status quo but this is obviously a
divided uh knesset
how much support is there for
keeping the status quo for changing it
is is it a matter of there just not
being adequate security to ensure that
the the agreement is upheld in the
compound or is there a willful um
movement to change the status quo there
well i think that there is uh one place
in jerusalem maybe in the middle east
which is more fragile and unstable
than
sharif at the temple mount and this is
the chair of prime minister bennett and
i think that
everything
uh is
part of the instability of the
government i think that this is uh why
uh
there is no question that israel is
violating the status quo
thousands of jews were allowed to go
there uh to to pray
and uh uh the fact of the matter is that
there is no price tag to this not in
middle east currency diplomatic currency
we don't see any gulf country calling
their ambassador back or the jordanian
flag
taken down
the
voices from washington
are also quite mild
so
for bennett when the balance is between
the stability of the government
and the coalition
the voices that are coming from his own
party
that are protesting the status quo
challenging the status quo so of course
he has to pay lip service that
especially lapid um that they respect
the status quo because we have interest
in the gulf we have interest in jordan
but we don't have interest in ramallah
and we don't have interest in east
jerusalem but the status quo and here
the status quo
in on the temple mount is a kind of uh
oxymoron with the status quo
in the peace negotiations that are going
nowhere
uh mr ramikori i'd like to cross over to
you now if we accept that there is uh
you know as we've heard is an erosion of
the status quo there what has led to
this is this a rise in popularity or
perhaps visibility of the ultra
nationalist of the far right what's the
sort of wider context here
the wider context i think is the
convergence of several trends that we've
seen over probably the last 20 years or
so and it's going faster now with this
right-wing
vulnerable israeli government
first of all the increase in right-wing
settler
you know
ethnic purity sentiment in israel that
the jews the israelis the zionists have
claimed to all the land from the river
to the sea
the second trend is the total weakness
of the palestinian leadership
lack of any serious leadership in
jerusalem for the palestinians but the
israelis have either jailed or expelled
or intimidated any serious indigenous
leadership
and the third element
is the lack of any external
accountability as akiva said that the
americans the europeans the arabs and
none of them are really
holding israel accountable
for the events and it's not just the
status quo the status quo is
a very limited uh focus has a focus on
the haram sharif the temple mount but
that's the most sensitive part of the
most sensitive district and the most
sensitive city
in the center of palestine at the heart
of the zionist arabist zionist
palestinian conflict going back 100
years
and the israelis have been steadily
trying to
strengthen their control over all of
jerusalem by expelling people jailing
people not renewing residence permits
intimidating people taking over land
annexing
areas building new settlements so this
is has to be seen as part of a much
bigger and much older process that goes
back
about 100 years but has been accelerated
because of the three uh reasons uh that
i mentioned and that's why
so strong because it's the only
resistance available to the people there
i'd like to pick up on on one of your
points the weakness of palestinian
leadership and put that to you uh mr
mustafa barghouti is palestinian
resistance to these changes is it
weakening
on the contrary
it is getting stronger the palestinian
authority is weak but the palestinian
people are not weak
and i think what we've seen in jerusalem
is a heroic act of resistance
popular nonviolent resistance standing
up to the power of the israeli army
and the provocations of the israeli
illegal settlers
and i think what we saw are palestinians
who are determined to demand their
freedom and protect their rights but
what we've seen also is very serious
provocation from the israeli side what
we've seen is very serious violation not
only of international law because the
whole march is about celebrating an
illegal act of annexing unoccupied
territory according to international law
this is unlawful and also what we have
seen is very serious violation of human
rights of palestinian people you can see
how the army is behaving
what we also saw is a reflection of the
how deep and profound the system of
israeli apartheid in palestine is
when you allow israelis to carry
thousands of flags and prevent
palestinians from carrying even a single
palestinian flag that is a reflection of
discrimination a reflection of
segregation a reflection of a terrible
system of apartheid that is much worse
than what prevailed in south africa but
more than that let me say what we've
seen in this march
the aggressive behavior of armed
illegal settlers against unarmed
palestinian civilians what was nothing
but fascist behavior i call it fascist
behavior because it was extreme it was
dangerous the people's lives were at
risk and the palestinians had nothing to
defend themselves while these armed
settlers were attacking them while the
israeli army not only observed but also
arrested any palestinian who tried to
defend himself
akiva elder i i want to talk to you a
little bit about the the flag day march
um also during the march we heard um
calls from some of these far-right
groups for the expulsion of all
palestinians and for the first time
publicly calling for the dismantling of
the dome of the rock i mean are these
views these once very um fringe views
now coming more into the mainstream
actually
it's not the first time
in the 80s a jewish underground members
of the jewish underground were arrested
before
they
exercised
their plan
to bomb the mosques
i'm afraid that
it's not a matter of a will it's a
matter of ability to do this there are
people who
are being interviewed about it and they
talk about it openly that it's time to
get rid of the mosque and the
palestinian sharif and to build a third
israeli mock you could see yesterday
children with t-shirts on the back of
them
it was it's time to build the third
mosque now
the other thing is that we
give this government which is completely
aware of it
uh
the benefits
of uh being the alternative to benjamin
netanyahu if netanyahu was prime
minister they israeli left and uh
the international community
would be all over him
but uh since we are so happy that we
have lapid as foreign minister and not
itamar benveil because what we hear
from the government is what do you want
uh you want us
uh to
bring down this government headed by
bennett and lapid and to get
bengavi as being the minister of police
so
the israeli public is intimidated both
from the hamas who is wanting to shoot
rockets on on israel on tel aviv on
jerusalem what happened two years ago
and are intimidated by netanyahu who is
provoking this government by sending
those people and inciting the people
against this government so uh and on the
other hand i see the weakness of the
palestinian authority because they are
also kind of subcontractors of this
government um and i remember i
interviewed professor sereno seba a few
years ago and he said it's time to run
for mayorship and he said that he's
considering now you know it's 55 years
of the occupation of jerusalem and what
we see from the central bureau of
statistics in israel that the
palestinians are now about 40
of the inhabitants of journalism and
they have the right to write and they
can form a coalition
with the israeli uh jewish left and
maybe even with the ultra orthodox and
they can build mosques whenever wherever
they want and stop building settlements
in east jerusalem but they don't do this
for some reason
you know i'm i can just see i want to
pause you there because i can see uh
mustafa barghouthi uh would like to add
something go ahead mr barghouti
well first of all i want to say there is
not the real difference between
netanyahu and nathalie bennett or the
government of netanyahu and the
government of naftali bennett stanley
bennett himself was a leader of settlers
he was the director of the regional uh
council of the settlements
he himself is an extreme
uh extreme right-winger like netanyahu
he was even the chief of staff of
netanyahu
and i think the rest of the israeli
government i think it's shameful that
some parties like merits who claim to be
on the left is supporting this
government
and uh the same applies to mansur abbas
by the way who is palestinian
i think these people have to bring down
this government after this fascist
behavior but more important uh i don't i
totally disagree with mr
ekiba on the issue of municipality
elections no
if you don't want to state solution
let's have one democratic state with
equal rights for everybody not
municipality elections in jerusalem
under occupation under a system of
segregation and apartheid and a law that
says that self-determination in the land
of palestine is exclusive to jewish
people no you don't want to state
solution fine let's have one state
solution one democratic state solution
and not one apartheid state in which
case we can run for a joint parliament
and and and that country will not be
jewish only
this is the reality if you want to speak
about democracy and not only be
exclusive to elections in in jerusalem
this would be a big mistake because that
would mean that we palestinians are
accepting not only occupation but also
the rules of the system of apartheid
ramen corrie i'd like to come back to
you um and just pick up on something you
uh spoke about earlier about um sort of
what repercussions there are for israel
failing to uphold the agreed status quo
around the al-aqsa mosque compound
is um sort of wider arab resistance
weakening those that once purported to
be strong defenders of the palestinian
cause
perhaps not so committed anymore
there's clearly a change among some arab
leaderships
in countries
that are
afraid
of their
governments and rulers as continued
ability to stay in power and therefore
cling to external support mainly from
the united states
and now
increasingly from israel these are
countries that are essentially being
de-sovereignized they're losing their
sovereignty they can't make
decisions about defense equipment they
want to buy where they get their water
where they get their food without
getting the approval of either the
israeli or the american government and
the funds to do so and and therefore
there clearly
is a decline in palestinian supporting
the palestinian caused by a few
governments but the overwhelming
majority of our people which is
repeatedly affirmed in public opinion
polling
supports the palestinian people and
supports a fair two-state resolution or
a single state so that the jewish
israelis who are in palestine and in
israel can stay there but they can't
stay there as occupiers in an apartheid
state and the palestinians must have
their state and their refugee hood uh
must be
resolved uh so this is a bigger issue
that really the significant thing that's
happening broadly
if we if we zoom out from just the from
the oxen
and the haram sharif temple mount the
biggest thing that's happening now and
it's been going on since last may june
is the reframing of the israel-palestine
conflict
in terms of both apartheid and ethnic
cleansing and a century-long conflict
between settler colonialists coming from
abroad and indigenous palestinians who
were 94 of the majority 100 years ago in
in this area the irony and the thing
that's important for israelis is that
arab palestinians between the jordan
river and the mediterranean in mandated
palestine now make up
just over 50 of the population there are
more arab palestinians than there are
jewish israelis in this land and this
trend is going to continue and this is
what's driving some of the uh some of
the extremism and one last point i'd add
increasingly significant is the trend we
see here in the united states where just
the other day
60 congress peep men and women put out a
statement
to
the
statement to wrote a letter to the to
the government
in the u.s to stop
take a position on the ethnic hunting
that the israelis are doing in
musafrietta which is the the villages
south of hebron so when you get 60
people in the american congress publicly
uh challenging the the colonial policies
of the israelis
this is significant it's not a majority
but it's starting to happen and this is
mirrored all over the united states
where there's a more
there's a greater demand for equal
rights for israelis and palestinians and
this scares zionists
uh we're nearing the end of the program
so i'd like to just pass back over to
mustafa barghouti do you agree with that
analysis about there being a reframing
uh of everything and and sort of how
that's being communicated i guess
i do absolutely i do agree because i
think that is the result of the fact
that when palestinians accepted a very
painful compromise
of having a state in west bengal and
east jerusalem
accepting practically a state in less
than half of what yuan decided we should
have
the israelis rejected that and made
every possible obstacle to the
possibility of the establishment of the
palestinian state
and that israeli rejection regardless of
who was a prime minister in israel
whether it was
the whole
compromise and because of that i think
palestine with the settlement expansion
i think palestinians are coming now to
going back to the very roots of the
ratio that this is one place and we are
indicted to full equality and we are
entitled to remove the effects of the
settler colonial system
and the issue of ethnic cleansing have
to be addressed which was practiced in
1948 forcing what is now six and a half
million palestinian refugees so i think
yes i do agree because i think
palestinians now see and believe that
israel does not want and did not want a
historical compromise all right we'll
have to leave it there for time uh thank
you very much for joining us mustafa
bharati akiva alder and rami khori
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vanel and
the whole team here bye-bye for now
you